[Orientalische Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Heute beginnt auf meinem Kanal der Ramadan-Monat
bzw. die Ramadan-Saison.
Der Ramadan-Monat fängt nächste Woche an
und das ist der Fastenmonat der Muslime.
Auf meinem Kanal und in meiner App und auf meinem Blog
findet ihr bereits ganz viele Rezepte dazu.
Der Ramadan-Monat geht praktisch 30 Tage.
Da wird den Tag über gefastet, abends gibt es dann das Fastenbrechen.
Abends darf man auch wieder Essen und Trinken zu sich nehmen.
Auf meinem Kanal findet ihr, wie gesagt, schon einige Rezepte.
Heute möchte ich mit etwas Süßem starten.
Was ich dieses Jahr auch machen werde:
Weil man ja morgens bis zu einer bestimmten Uhrzeit nur essen darf
- bis Sonnenaufgang - habe ich mir gedacht -
finde ich es immer ganz gut,
wenn man Müsli, Porridge oder Haferbrei isst,
weil das einfach den Tag über satt hält
und man so ganz viele Nährstoffe, Ballaststoffe und Vitamine
zu sich nehmen kann.
Deswegen gibt es auf meinem Kanal
bzw. in meiner App in der Kategorie „Porridge“
noch weitere Frühstücksideen, die ihr abends schon vorbereiten
und morgens essen könnt
und habt einfach etwas Gesundes, Leckeres für den Start in den Tag.
Also da könnt ihr auf jeden Fall vorbeischauen.
In der Ramadan-Kategorie sind auch ganz viele Rezepte verlinkt.
Heute starte ich in diesem Jahr mit einem süßen Rezept,
nämlich mit einem Pistazien-Milchkuchen,
weil Pistazien eigentlich schon etwas
sehr Orientalisches und Türkisches sind.
Sie werden ganz oft benutzt.
Ich weiß, dass in Deutschland viele Pistazien nicht so oft benutzen,
aber es ist wirklich etwas sehr Leckeres.
Man muss auch dazu sagen, sie sind relativ teuer.
Deswegen benutze ich keine 200 g in einem Rezept,
sondern gehe schon sparsam damit um.
Aber das Aroma ist einfach sehr lecker!
Heute starte ich hier mit dem Rührkuchen.
Dafür nehme ich 4 Eier, 100 g Zucker, eine Prise Salz
und etwas Vanilleextrakt, jeweils 50 g Pistazien und Mandeln
– die sind bereits gehäutet –,
100 g Mehl und 1/2 TL Backpulver.
Den Ofen habe ich bereits auf 170°C Ober-/Unterhitze vorgeheizt.
Ich werde den Kuchen gleich rund backen,
weil ich es einfach schöner finde,
aber wenn ihr sagt, zum Ramadan möchte ich den gerne eckig haben,
dann könnt ihr auch die Umrechnungsfunktion
in meinem Blog oder in der App benutzen,
denn dann könnt ihr jede Form,
also egal, ob ein großes Blech oder nur eine kleine Form,
einfach umrechnen lassen.
Vor allem an Ramadan kann man schöne kleine Kuchenstücke servieren,
Gerade abends als Dessert finde ich das doch ganz gut.
Jetzt nehmt ihr zuerst die Eier – die kommen in die Rührschüssel.
Da ist nur wichtig, dass sie zimmerwarm sind,
damit sie sich gleich besser aufschlagen lassen.
Dann Zucker, Salz und Vanilleextrakt dazu.
Dann dürft ihr diese Masse etwa 5-10 Minuten schön cremig verrühren.
Ich werde in der Zwischenzeit die Mandeln und die Pistazien hacken.
Bei den Pistazien und Mandeln ist es so –
die Mandeln habe ich ohne Haut, ohne diese braune Haut außen herum.
Falls ihr sie so nicht bekommt, könnt ihr auch die mit Haut nehmen
oder ihr übergießt sie einfach mit kochendem Wasser,
lasst sie 10 Minuten stehen
und dann könnt ihr die Haut einfach so abziehen.
Dann könnt ihr sie auch fein hacken.
[Musik]
So soll die Zuckermasse dann aussehen, die Eier-Zuckermasse –
schön dickcremig.
Hier habe ich bereits Backpulver und Mehl vermischt,
kann die Zutaten kurz dazu sieben.
[Musik]
Dann kurz unterheben.
Es ist jetzt einfach ein ganz normaler Biskuit.
[Musik]
Ich nehme jetzt hier einfach mein Lochblech mit einem Backring,
den ich auf 22 cm eingestellt habe.
Jetzt kann ich hier die Mandeln und die Pistazien
auf den Boden streuen - dann habe ich so einen Knusperboden.
[Musik]
Dann kommt jetzt hier die Masse darauf, wird glattgestrichen
und dann kann der Kuchen gebacken werden.
Ich kann mich in der Zwischenzeit
schon einmal um die Pistazienmilch kümmern.
[Musik und Uhr]
Für die Pistazienmilch nehme ich
70 g Pistazien, 200 g Milch, 50 g Zucker und 200 g Sahne.
Was ich jetzt zuerst machen werde:
Ich nehme etwa die Hälfte der Milch und gebe sie in den Mixer,
gebe da die Pistazien dazu. Dann kann ich die Milch darin pürieren.
Die übrige Milch gebe ich in den Topf und gebe da den Zucker dazu,
damit der sich auflösen kann.
[Musik]
Jetzt einfach kurz aufkochen lassen und ein bisschen rühren,
damit sich der Zucker schön löst.
Also ich muss sagen,
die Pistazienmilch riecht jetzt schon sehr lecker.
Ich glaube, der Kuchen wird echt gut.
Hier könnt ihr theoretisch die Pistazienmilch
einfach schon einmal auskratzen und zur Sahne geben,
denn diese Zutaten werde ich gar nicht mitkochen.
Dann kühlt auch die Zuckermilch einfach ein bisschen schneller ab.
[Musik]
Da sieht man dann auch schon ganz gut,
dass der Zucker sich gelöst hat.
Ich spüle damit jetzt nur noch kurz den Mixer aus,
damit die Pistazien da nicht verschwendet werden.
Ich mixe es einmal kurz durch
und dann habe ich wirklich schön alle Reste
und kann dann die Milch abkühlen lassen.
Wenn ihr wollt, dass der Pistazienkuchen so richtig schön grün ist,
dürft ihr auch gerne noch ein bisschen Lebensmittelfarbe dazugeben.
Ich finde, wenn man jetzt so viele Pistazien nimmt,
dass der Kuchen ganz grün wird, wird es halt schon mächtig teuer
Deswegen könnt da ruhig mit Lebensmittelfarbe nachhelfen
oder ihr sagt, ihr belasst es einfach bei der natürlichen Farbe.
[Musik]
So, dann lasse ich es abkühlen, den Kuchen fertig backen
und dann geht es gleich weiter.
Ich glaube, da machen wir uns jetzt noch einen Smoothie.
[Musik]
Der Kuchen ist gebacken.
Ich habe jetzt praktisch eine Stäbchenprobe gemacht.
Wenn da nichts mehr daran hängt, dann ist er perfekt.
Jetzt werde ich den Kuchen aber noch einstechen.
Das könnt ihr jetzt auch
mit einem Zahnstocher, Schaschlikspieß oder einer Gabel machen,
wobei eine Gabel nicht ganz so gut geeignet ist,
da man damit nicht bis ganz nach unten kommt -
deswegen lieber so einen Kuchentester oder einen Schaschlikspieß.
Jetzt hier ein bisschen einstechen und dann mit der Milch übergießen.
[Musik]
Hier noch einmal durchrühren und dann am besten am Rand anfangen
und langsam übergießen.
Jetzt lasse ich das erst einmal kurz einziehen
und gieße dann noch eine Schicht darüber.
So, ungefähr 100 ml lasse ich jetzt übrig.
Wenn ihr jetzt alles hineingießt,
dann bildet sich in der Mitte so eine Kuhle.
Deswegen kurz warten, bis es einzieht
und dann noch einmal darüber gießen.
Zum Servieren lassen wir dann noch etwas übrig.
[Musik]
Die Pistazienmilch ist jetzt gut in den Kuchen eingezogen.
Ich habe das Ganze in den Kühlschrank gestellt,
damit es auch schön kalt wird.
Jetzt kann ich hier schon einmal die Sahnecreme zubereiten.
Da mache ich jetzt eine Quarksahne.
Ihr könnt aber auch eine Joghurtsahne machen
oder etwas mit Frischkäse zubereiten.
Wichtig ist nur, dass es jetzt nicht zu süß wird,
denn die Pistazienmilch war ja jetzt auch schon leicht gesüßt.
Dafür nehme ich 250 g Quark, 50 g Puderzucker, 1 Limette
– davon brauche ich den Abrieb –,
200 g Sahne und etwas San-apart.
Jetzt könnt ihr direkt den Quark hier in die Schüssel geben.
Dann den Puderzucker und Limettenabrieb dazu.
Da bitte darauf achten, dass es Limetten sind,
deren Schale man mit verzehren kann –
steht meist darauf „unbehandelt“ oder „Schale zum Verzehr geeignet“,
denn Bio heißt auch nicht immer gleich ungespritzt.
Davon nehme ich jetzt gar nicht so viel,
sondern wirklich nur einen Hauch.
Dann kurz verrühren, die Sahne zugießen
und mit San-apart steif schlagen.
[Musik und Handrührgerät]
Handrührgerät runterschalten beim Sahnezugießen.
[Musik]
Den Kuchen ziehe ich jetzt hier auf einen Tortenretter.
Dann könnt ihr den Tortenring lösen.
Ups, ich habe den vorhin schon gelöst. [Lacht]
Ich habe mich jetzt selbst verraten.
Könnt ihn lösen, aber wieder drumherum spannen.
Das, was ihr hier auf der Oberfläche seht,
sind praktisch die zerkleinerten Pistazien
und noch ein bisschen Restsahne.
Ich habe ja noch ein bisschen etwas im Behälter aufbewahrt.
Jetzt noch die Folie darunter weg.
Jetzt kommt hier die Tortencreme darauf.
Dann könnt ihr sie schön verstreichen,
entweder wellig oder in die Mitte gleich mit einer Palette...
- das zeige ich euch gleich -
In die Mitte ein schönes Muster mit der Palette ziehen.
Aber wenn ihr wollt, könnt sie auch so einfach wellig machen,
dass da kleine Spitzen hochgucken.
Oder ihr könnt auch einen Spritzbeutel nehmen.
Ursprünglich war das sogar mein Plan, aber jetzt nicht mehr.
Ich nehme jetzt so eine kleine Palette.
Ihr könnt auch einen Löffel oder ein Messer nehmen.
Dann in der Mitte ansetzen und nach außen ziehen.
[Musik]
Ich habe hier jetzt noch einmal gehackte Pistazien.
Die streue ich hier an den Rand.
Oh, es wäre auch süß gewesen – so die Spiral entlang,
aber da muss man sehr präzise arbeiten, dass man sie noch erkennt.
Wenn ihr möchtet, gerne noch essbare Blüten.
Die, finde ich, passen hier ganz gut dazu.
[Musik]
Ich liebe die essbaren Blüten
Die nehme ich ganz oft für Salate oder eben auch für Gebäck.
Die geben dem Ganzen so ein schönes Aroma,
weil sie einfach wunderbar nach Blüten riechen.
Die Torte ist jetzt im Prinzip fertig.
Ich werde sie allerdings noch kühlstellen müssen
- für mindestens 2 Stunden, am besten aber auch über Nacht.
So mache ich das jetzt und dann probieren wir morgen direkt die Torte.
Ich decke sie einfach mit einem Tortenretter ab.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist das erste diesjährige Ramadan-Rezept fertig.
Murat ist gerade drüben auf der Baustelle.
Deswegen, würde ich sagen,
darf unsere Hobby-Türkin probieren. [Lacht]
Sarah, pasta denemek istermisin? (Möchtest du den Kuchen probieren?)
SARAH: Evet, isterim. (Ja, ich möchte.)
SALLY: Gel. (Komm!)
SARAH: Maşallah. (Großartig.)
[Beide lachen].
Ist der schön.
SALLY: Çok güzel. (Der ist sehr schön.)
SARAH: Çok güzel.
[Sally lacht]
Allahım yarabbim. (Großer allmächtiger Gott.)
[Beide lachen]
SALLY: Ich sag’s doch: Hobby-Türkin.
SARAH: Oh, der ist aber echt so schön. Fast zu schade zum Essen.
SALLY: Ich finde auch, der ist schön geworden.
SARAH: Mit den Blüten.
SALLY: Der riecht auch so gut.
Ich finde, der riecht so richtig blumig.
Man riecht sie richtig gut heraus...
SARAH: ... die Pistazie.
BEIDE: Oh!
SALLY: Ich habe auch noch...
SARAH: Der Verlauf!
[Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Ich habe auch noch von der Milch etwas da.
Also man kann auch noch auf den Teller...
SARAH: ... so dass der Kuchen ein bisschen...
SALLY: Ja, so getränkt wird. Oh schön!
SARAH: Und dann Blüten darauf.
SALLY: Ja! Oh, so machen wir das gleich.
Unser Serviervorschlag folgt. [Sarah lacht]
Buyur. (Bitte schön.)
SARAH: Teşekkürler. (Danke)
SALLY: Rica ederim. (Bitte)
[Beide lachen]
Jetzt brauchen wir schon Untertitel für unsere Videos,
weil du so gut Türkisch sprichst.
SARAH: Oh!
[Sally lacht]
Der ist ein Kunst... Oh, das wusste ich gar nicht.
SALLY: Ja, der hat einen Crunch-Boden.
SARAH: Maşallah.
[Beide lachen]
SALLY: Ich dachte, jetzt kommt „Allahım yarabbim.“ [Lacht]
SARAH: Mmh! Mmh!
SALLY: Mmh!
SARAH: Mmh!
[Beide lachen]
Mmh! Das ist Zitrone drin!
SALLY: Hmm! Oh ist das lecker! [Sarah stimmt zu.]
SARAH: Oh, der schmeckt richtig nach Frühling.
SALLY: Ich hatte kurz vergessen, wie ich die Creme gemacht habe,
aber dann fiel es mir wieder ein. Ja, die ist...
SARAH: Das schmeckt man sofort. Sehr fruchtig.
SALLY: Ja. Ich muss sagen,
diese Pistazienmilch ist nicht so gut eingezogen wie bei dem Trileçe.
Liegt wohl daran, dass die Pistazien einfach zu grob sind,
aber ich finde das so gar nicht schlimm,
weil ich finde, die Sauce kann man jetzt dazu essen.
Sehr schön.
SARAH: Ich finde, das hat einen schönen Effekt.
SALLY: Ja, hat so einen schönen Verlauf mit drin.
SARAH: Schön grün.
SALLY: Also, falls ihr diese Torte gerne einmal ausprobieren wollt
- so sieht sie von innen aus -
dann schaut gerne auf Sallys-Blog.de vorbei oder in meiner App.
Da findet ihr auch die Rezepte.
Wie gesagt, könnt ihr den Kuchen rund oder eckig machen.
Eckig als Schnitte ist er auch hübsch.
SARAH: Aber ich finde rund schöner.
SALLY: Ja, runde Torten sind schon immer schöner.
Eckig ist einfacher zu portionieren,
weil man wirklich dann auch einmal ganz kleine Stückchen machen kann.
SARAH: Wer will davon ein kleines Stück?
SALLY: Ja! Außer abends vielleicht, so nach dem Fastenbrechen dann...
SARAH: Großes Stück!
SALLY: Okay, Sarah. Sarah nimmt ein großes Stück. [Lacht]
Also wie gesagt,
dieses Rezept und viele weitere findet ihr in meiner App.
Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß beim Nachbacken.
Probiert die Torte gerne einmal aus
und sagt mir dann, wie sie euch geschmeckt hat.
SARAH: Sehr lecker!
SALLY: Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss! Hoşçakal. (Tschüss.)
SARAH: Hoşçakal. [Sally lacht] Voll der gleiche Ton.
[Beide lachen]
Oh, der ist echt...
SALLY: [Stimmt zu] Eigentlich müsstest du noch sagen:
„Hayırlı Ramazanlar!“
SARAH: Genau. Was?
SALLY: Um den Ramadan-Monat praktisch so... gesegnetes Ramadan...
SARAH: Ja.
SALLY: ... wünschen möchtest: Hayırlı Ramazanlar.
SARAH: Hayırlı
SALLY: Ramazanlar.
SARAH: Ramazanlar.
SALLY: Ja! Aferin! (Sehr gut!)
SARAH: Afiyet olsun. (Guten Appetit)
SALLY: Afiyet olsun.
SARAH: Günaydın. (Guten Morgen.)
[Musik]